buta an italian who's a China political
analyst he's joining us via Skype from
Beijing thanks for talking to us the
world is waiting the world is watching
waiting really for Beijing to snap how
provocative is this an action as far as
Beijing is concerned well it's very
provocative I mean this this is more
than just civil disobedience they're
really impacting the economy of Hong
Kong remember Hong Kong is one of the
biggest destinations in the world at
hosts it's just a huge upper persons if
you think seven million people who are
residents there and you have over 30
million people who are visiting on a
yearly basis this could have a very big
impact on the Hong Kong economy remember
Hong Kong does not pay taxes to the
mainland they only are all tax money
stay within and it's it's a situation
where it's it's passed it seems to be
fast deteriorating that's not the
situation yesterday when they were just
standing by right now the language
coming from Beijing is also ratcheting
up isn't it they've talked about this
being a form of terrorism and they've
called this a color revolution what are
the options before Beijing in terms of
their response to what is going on in
Hong Kong well there's this article 18
under the basic laws which allows the
Hong Kong government if they feel that
they need help in restoring a civil
society they can ask for the PLA to come
in but there's another option as well if
China the mainland sees this as a
foreign interference then they would be
allowed to come in because it would be
defense of the nation and if there is
any evidence that there are outside
forces there's strong suspicions given
the meetings by pro-democracy
independence who are seeking regime
change with United States officials also
with officials from the embassy in Hong
Kong this is fueling this feeling that
the this is part of the old pressure
tactics that Donald Trump likes to use
when he's negotiating just like with
Taiwan and the battle
going through there in the trade war
right but the authorities in Beijing
will be well aware that perhaps it would
be the worst possible situation just in
terms of the optics of it if there were
to be Chinese military presence on the
streets of Hong Kong contravening what
is supposed to be this this one country
two systems' arrangement with is which
is still in place supposed to still be
in place until twenty forty nine it
would really backfire for China
well optics yes and this is
unfortunately what has happened this has
turned into a PR war obviously there are
people or entities who are intent on
provoking Beijing into reacting this way
Beijing has shown a lot of restraint but
there comes a point if you know at some
point people start dying on either side
police or on the protest side and order
cannot be restored and the city cannot
function then you have a breakdown in
civil society now that would not be in
contravention of the basic laws if the
Hong Kong government requests it or if
it gets to a point where it's obvious
that things cannot be restored by the
local authorities right and there's
another option as well isn't there I'm
wondering and wondering how it sort of
viable it is and that is for the Carrie
Lam administration to actually sit down
and talk to the protesters and try to
get a handle on what their grievances
are I mean what about that as an option
sounds wonderful who would you talk to
there are no quote leaders out there
there are people who sit on the
periphery and say they're not leaders
they're founders of democratic parties
they're students and things like that
but this movement is a mop it doesn't
have any leaders so who do you sit down
with and remember that this has been an
escalating situation at first was all
about the extradition treaty which was
overblown as political theater now has
changed to regime change that are people
insisting on universal suffrage and that
the the basic laws be changed in order
to make
Hong Kong in essence an independent
democratic a separate country ina
tagging good to talk to you thank you
very much thank you